as to your question about what would I
be doing if I hadn't taken psychedelics
well I don't know what I was doing what
I assumed I would end up doing before I
took psychedelics was hopefully end up
teaching art history in a very exclusive
Eastern girls school somewhere for a
long long time it was a kind of Nabokov
II and luxury with my life's plan
[Music]
it's like realizing and embracing the
fact that you're an actor I grapple with
this all the time because when I'm
brushing my teeth I find myself humming
there's no business like no people like
show people they understand that
psychedelics are a blowtorch to their
IceCube they don't want to get near it
you know they used to have the excuse
that they even though they were gonna
spend a lifetime criticizing
psychedelics they couldn't invest six
hours to find out what it was about well
so then we brought them DMT which lasts
five minutes so now the new excuse is
well as a professional person I don't
choose to break the law fine here's some
alpha salva Noreen its unscheduled it
lasts five minutes it'll cut your head
off will you do it and they say well no
I have a heart murmur or I have an
appointment in 20 minutes or something
there is absolute terror to confront the
reality of what this represents my idea
of how to do the guide is okay I'm going
to take six grams of mushrooms I will be
in this room here is a closed door you
be on the other side of this closed door
and if I
this Bell three times you may open the
door a crack and say what that's the
guide the idea I mean I've heard people
say you know I took mushrooms and I was
just beginning to work it out and then
the guide said will now remember you
wanted to work on some issues while you
were loaded now what about your
impending gum surgery divorce bankruptcy
and the same I was touching dad do you
mind I got into this like the gentleman
who asked the question is by being in
the Amazon by having searched India to
see so you know what can you show me and
they couldn't show me anything they
wanted me to sweep the ashram for twelve
years and then something wonderful was
going to happen and I am back then when
I got to South America I said well can
you show me and I said let's sharpen our
machetes we'll go out here and let some
of this snake vine and come back and
I'll show you and by 10 o'clock that
night you know I was sobbing in the
guy's arms he told me I was a convert
I'd sweep his courtyard for twelve years
without asking
to put the greatness of writers in
perspective I'll tell you a story about
the last time I dealt with my publisher
at Bantam in New York sitting across
from those people above the 50th floor
how I come off to them is well now let's
see mr. Mackenna
we have current sales figures in front
of us you're kind of a 60,000 copy kind
of guy aren't you and frankly mr.
Mackenna around here that really butters
no bread we're interested in the million
plus seller we can carry people like you
of course given that we have substantial
successes in other fields but and on and
on like that to which I replied so I
guess you're not taking me to dinner at
Elaine's which was true not even tea you
cannot be half slave and half free you
cannot be half piss and half yup no I
don't know I have no idea why
you know what we can arrange it I just
never bother because I smoke too much
dope frankly worried about stuff like
that I mean it sounds like a splendid
idea like so much that would happen if I
stopped smoking here what happens is
that this stuff which we call mind takes
the shape of its container the way water
takes the shape of the container and
when mind is folded down into the tiny
eensy-beensy cramped container of
bourgeois American materialist
Republican haole existence becomes a
kind of a narrow experience of some sort
you know what I mean in a sense what
nature does is make the body a less and
less comfortable place to be until
finally you just say alright already you
know take me being me up Scotty I mean I
tend toward row row row your boat gently
down the stream merrily merrily merrily
life is but a dream
I know people like show people
[Music]